[Music]
my planet arrakis is so beautiful when
the sun is low
rolling over the sands you can see spice
in the air
the outsiders ravage our lands in front
of our eyes
their cruelty to my people is all i've
known
what's to become of our world
a boy hey duncan can i trust you
something
yes always you know that i've been
having dreams
about a girl on maracas i don't know
what it means
dreams make good stories but everything
important happens when we're awake
hey you put on some muscle i didn't no
[Applause]
we are house atreides there is no call
we do not answer
there is no faith that we betrayed
smile gurney i am smiling the emperor
asks us to bring peace to arrakis house
atreides
accepts
you need to face your fears
come with me
you need to be ready you've never met
us before they're not human they're
brutal
the duke's son sees too much
this is why dude kill them all
god in heaven
[Music]
get everything with guns off the ground
go
this is an extermination
they're picking my family off one by one
let's fight by demons
dad what if i'm not the future of house
of treaties
a great man doesn't seek to lead he's
called to it
but if your answer is no
you'll still be the only thing i ever
needed you to be
my son
[Applause]
if anything happens
will you protect paul with my life
all together can we stand a chance
it's time
there's something happening to me
there's something awakening in my mind i
can't control it
what did you see
there's a crusade coming
do you often dream things that happen
just as you dream them
yes
the test is simple remove your hand from
the box
and you die what's in the box
pain
[Applause]
you inherit too much power you have
proven you can rule yourself
now you must learn to rule others
something
none of your ancestors learnt
my father rules an entire planet he's
losing it
he's getting a richer one he'll lose
that one too
arrakis is a death trap
this is an extermination
[Applause]
they're taking my family off one by one
let's fight my demons
an animal caught in a trap will nor off
its own leg
to escape what will you do
[Music]
i know you
[Music]
one day the legend will be born
all of civilization depends on it
the future i can see it
[Music]
i must not fear
[Music]
fear is the mind killer
fellow duke where the fear is gone
only i will remain
go go
you